Google VO 3.1 just dropped and it
completely crushes Soore 2 because it's
not just higher quality. It also has a
much better understanding of your
prompts and generates results much
faster. But the biggest change is that
you can now control your start and end
frames which means you can generate
results that look just like this. So
I've been testing it over the past few
days and in this video I'm going to
break down everything you need to know
about VO3.1. How it works, what's new,
and how you can use it to its full
potential inside one secret tool. Well,
the first thing is just much richer and
better audio overall. You'll notice that
the sound you get now is a lot more
detailed and just feels higher quality
in general. The second thing is kind of
just overall improvements across the
board. The prompt adherence got way
better, which basically means VO 3.1
follows what you write a lot more
accurately now. The video quality itself
has also improved. So, the textures,
lighting, and everything just look way
more lifelike. The motion feels
smoother, too, so the videos you get out
of it just look more natural overall.
They've also made some really nice
upgrades to the imagetovideo feature. It
works a lot better now and supports the
new start and end frame feature, which
is a big one that basically lets you
decide exactly how your video begins and
ends no matter how long it is. So, you
get full control over the final result
instead of just letting the AI decide it
for you. There's also this new thing
called frames, which is actually pretty
cool. It lets you upload up to three
different images and then Google VO
builds out a full video using those. So,
you can basically control the look, the
pacing, and the story just by picking a
few reference frames. Now, the tool
we're going to be using to access Google
VO 3.1 is actually called Open Art. And
the reason I like using Open Art is
because it lets you access all of these
new AI models basically as soon as
they're released. Plus, it's all in one
place. You can create your images, your
audio, and your videos without having to
switch between different apps or tabs.
You can even make your starting and
ending frames right inside the same tool
and then turn them into a full video
with just a couple of clicks. So, for
our first video, I just wanted to show
you the difference between the two
versions, VO 3.0 and VO 3.1 to access
Google VO. I'm just going to click on
the video section right here, then go to
text settings so I can start from a text
prompt, and then I'll paste my prompt in
here. All right, so for the prompt, I'm
going with this. A weathered sea captain
with a thick gray beard and blue knitted
hat stands at a ship's railing gesturing
towards stormy ocean waves. Cinematic
close-up with slow dollian on his
weathered face. Golden hour lighting
with dramatic shadows. He says, "The
ocean teaches you respect one wave at a
time. Audio ocean waves crashing wind.
No background music. Color palette. Deep
blues, warm amber, weathered browns, no
subtitles. Now I'm going to start by
selecting the old version first. I'll
set the resolution to the highest
possible. keep video motion on normal
and then click generate. Once that's
running, I'm switching over to version
3.1. And as you can see, Open Art
actually saves my prompt automatically,
which means I don't need to re-enter
anything. I'll just change the aspect
ratio to 16 to9. Make sure all the
settings are the same as before and then
hit create. I'll wait for both
generations to finish. And let's take a
look at the results.
>> The ocean teaches you respect one wave
at a time.
The ocean teaches you respect
one wave at a time.
As you can hear, not only is the audio
quality noticeably better, but the
overall visual quality is too. In Google
VO 3.1, the face looks way more
realistic. It doesn't have that slightly
plastic AI generated look anymore. The
textures on his clothing, the detail in
his beard and skin, even the lighting,
it all feels more natural and realistic.
And honestly, I think his voice in the
newer model also fits his look way
better. It just looks more believable
overall. Now that we've seen that
comparison, let's go ahead and generate
some more videos using Google VO 3.1.
The first thing I'll do is hop over to
the elements button. And here we're
going to test out the new feature that
lets you drop in up to three different
images and then generate a full video
using all of them. So, first off, we
need to get some images. For that, I'm
going to use the image generator inside
Open Art. I'll switch over to the image
section. And for this first one, I'll
select the Open Art photorealistic
model. For the image of our person, I'll
type in woman in her 20s and then click
create. As you can see, we instantly get
a really nice realistic looking result.
Next, I'm going to switch the model to
Cadream 4. For this one, I want an image
of a statue. So, I'll write a huge
marble statue. Then, I'll click create.
And as you can see, we get a really nice
looking statue image that fits
perfectly. For this scene, I'll type in
a quiet park at sunset and then click
create. As you can see, the result looks
beautiful. The sky glows in warm shades
of orange and pink, casting soft light
across the park. Now, I'm just going to
download all of these images, then head
back over to the video section, click
elements again, and upload all of my
images there. For the prompt, I'll
write, "A marble statue stands in a
quiet park at sunset. A woman looks up
at it, talking about how people once
tried to capture feelings in stone, and
somehow they did." Then I'll click
generate and let's take a look at what
we get.
>> They tried to capture feelings in stone
and somehow they did.
>> As you can see, the result looks
amazing. It flawlessly uses both
reference images. The woman looks
exactly like the one we just generated.
And the statue looks super realistic.
The whole video feels natural, like an
actual shot of someone filming their
family member talking about a statue. I
also really like how it picked up the
sound of nature in the background. the
wind, the ambient noise, all of it just
adds to the realism. It genuinely feels
like a real moment, which is kind of
crazy considering it's fully AI
generated. And now, let's test out the
starting frame feature. This one's
actually really good for a bunch of
different things, especially for product
images, which we'll get into a bit
later. But first, I want to show you how
you can make generations where you can
set up people to look like brand logos.
So, for this one, I just wanted to
animate an infinity logo. I'll go into
the image section. Write my prompt here.
Aerial nighttime photograph of a giant
glowing open art infinity logo formed by
thousands of artists standing together
in a vast city square surrounded by
modern architecture and digital art
projections. Each person holds a glowing
tablet or holographic frame showing
different AI generated artworks creating
waves of color, neon blues, purples, and
soft golds that merge into the infinity
symbol. The logo radiates shifting
gradients of light symbolizing
creativity without limits. Drone
captured from directly above. Cinematic
contrast, ultradetailed 4K quality,
atmospheric haze, luminous reflections
on the pavement, futuristic yet human.
And then click generate. As you can see,
it gives us a really cool looking image.
You can actually see people holding
posters. There's this glowing light
around the logo, and it just looks
awesome. Now I'm going to go back to
video, import this image as my starting
frame into the image section right here.
Make sure I have version 3.1 selected.
Up the resolution, set video motion to
normal. And then I'll just use this
prompt right here. The people forming
the infinity symbol begin to move in
synchronized waves. In one loop, they
perform slow coordinated sit-ups,
creating a ripple effect of motion that
flows through the curve. In the other
loop, people rise and jump lightly in
rhythm. Their glowing tablets pulsing
brighter with each movement. The light
from their screens travels across the
logo like energy passing through a
circuit. Smooth, seamless, and perfectly
timed. As the rhythm builds, the two
sides of the infinity alternate between
waves of motion and stillness,
symbolizing constant creative flow. Once
it's done, you can see it gives us a
really, really nice looking result. The
people are moving, but they still stay
aligned with the original image. And
honestly, this is something brands could
easily use in their commercials to
highlight their logos in a super
creative way. But now, let's move into
some brand promo videos because this is
where the tool really gets good,
especially now that you can basically
create videos of any length you want.
All right, so the first thing you want
to do is, of course, start off by
finding a product. For this one, I'm
actually going to use this image of the
AirPods Max on this headphone stand.
Now, we need to create our secondary
image, which we'll be using as our end
frame. I want the ad to have the camera
slowly moving around the product and
then the product kind of transitions
into a different environment by the end.
So, I'm going to import my first image
into the image section right here. Then,
I'll use Nano Banana to switch things up
a bit by writing, change the product
environment to a solid black background,
and turn the headphones around. As you
can see, the image we get back looks
perfect for what I had in mind. So, now
I'll head back over to the video
section. Select Google VO 3.1 and import
both my starting frame and my end frame.
Finally, I'll use this prompt right
here. A premium silver white overear
headphone set with mesh cushion ear cups
and polished aluminum finish perched on
a minimalist white stand in a bright
white studio. At 2 seconds, the camera
begins with a wide shot and slowly zooms
in toward the headphone, emphasizing the
texture of the ear cushions and metal
sheen under soft studio lighting. At
around 3 seconds, the camera transitions
into a fast, fluid 180°ree orbit around
the headphone. Motion blur subtle,
capturing reflections as the stand and
background begin to fade. Finally, the
camera pulls back, zooms out gracefully,
revealing the full silhouette of the
floating headphone in the center of the
black background. style, ultra
minimalist, Apple commercial aesthetic,
shallow depth of field, high-end product
cinematography, clean reflections, no
subtitles, subtle ambient hum, plus
light whoosh sounds. Now, what's
different about this one is that you can
actually give it specific descriptions
for each part of the video, and it will
basically tailor the animation to that.
It's not perfect yet, but it's really,
really good at understanding those
transitions, and that's exactly what
we'll use here. Now, I'll click
generate, and let's take a look at our
result. As you can see, it came out
looking really cool. I'd say this is a
great result. The product stays
completely consistent throughout the
whole video, and the overall look is
super clean. But you can actually take
this a step further while still keeping
that same level of consistency. Here's
how you do it. You'd click the switch
button to swap your frames, making your
end frame the new starting frame. Then
you can import a new image for the new
end frame. In my case, I made a new
picture of the AirPods floating in space
with Earth behind them because I wanted
the product to kind of fly out into
space at the end, which gives it that
smooth futuristic vibe that fits the
design of the headphones really well.
So, for the new prompt, I'll paste this.
A premium silver white overear headphone
set with soft mesh ear cups and polished
aluminum finish suspended on a
minimalist white stand in a bright white
studio. At two seconds, wide shot,
camera slowly dollies in and zooms
toward the headphones, bringing the
texture of the mesh and metal
reflections into focus. At 3 seconds,
the camera begins a fast 180° orbit
around the headphones. Motion blur
subtle, capturing the polished surface.
Background remains white. Finally, the
camera pulls back, zoom out to reveal
the headphones hovering above a slowly
rotating Earth. Rimlit against space.
resolution ultra crisp 1080p 16-9
cinematic style. Make sure all the
settings are maxed out and then click
generate again. And as you can see, the
result came out looking amazing. But
what's really cool here and what I want
you to notice is that the transition
between both of these videos is
basically seamless. That's the key part.
This is what allows you to create
consistent videos, basically unlimited
in length, while keeping everything
perfectly aligned from one generation to
the next. So now you know exactly how to
use Google VO 3.1, how to generate your
videos, and even build full ads straight
from your images. And what makes all of
this so nice is that you can do it all
inside Open Art. You can create your
images, fine-tune your prompts, and then
take them directly into VO 3.1 without
ever leaving the platform. It's
literally everything, image, audio, and
video all in one place. So, if you want
to start creating professionallooking
videos with Google VO 3.1 yourself, go
sign up for Open Art using the link down
in the description below. I'll see you
guys in the next one.